all right Flutie Tootie Friday and uh  you guys are kind enough to save my  champagne glass  oh sorry so a traditional end of year  song I don't know where this song came  from but it has been around for hundreds  of years as folks say goodbye to one  year and say hello to another you know  this one sing along  [Music]  acquaintance Scotland  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Applause]  inside  [Music]  we'll take a cup of kindness yet  [Music]  I think's back there as well so happy  New Year to you we appreciate it as  Heather said we appreciate you guys  hanging out with us all year long Las  Vegas yes thank you so much cheers and  happy New Year see on Monday take care  [Music]